so thank you for years of dedication
support I sent along a little surprise
later this year we'll be releasing the
entire infinity Saga on home video and
as you can imagine it'll be jam-packed
with extra features and footage that no
one outside of Marvel Studios has ever
seen we actually have been around long
enough now we have a vault and we pulled
some things out of that vault that we
said we'll never show this to anybody
put it away
we're bringing them out we're putting
them on this disc and I'm about to show
you a deleted scene that has never been
seen by anyone before right now thank
you again so much and enjoy
Javad bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough I have to deal with a spoiled
brat who doesn't play well with others
and wants to keep all his toys to
himself the alien Nick Fury director of
shield I'm here to talk to you about the
Avenger initiative Oh what are we
avenging whatever the hell we want I am
you think you're the only superhero in
the world mr. stark you've become part
of a bigger universe you just don't know
who the hell are you Nick Fury director
of shield I'm here to talk to you about
the Avenger initiative welcome back
everybody it's Charlie we have to talk
about this bond that Kevin Feige just
dropped revealing that they planned on
spider-man and x-men crossover from the
very beginning of the MCU there's a
whole bunch of spider-man and x-men
Easter eggs and all this will break it
all down the reason why we're just
seeing this now is because as he says
they're releasing an infinity Saga box
set with all 23 films I've been waiting
for them to do that but they're putting
a bunch of never-before-seen footage on
that and this is just a taste for what
that is so I will do a special giveaway
for that giant box set when they release
it all you have to do to enter that is
be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about how they're going to
introduce x-men in the MCU all our minds
are blown by this but breaking all the
Easter eggs down top-five style as he
says as if gamma incidents radioactive
bug bites and a sort of mutants weren't
enough I have to play with a spoiled
brat who doesn't play well with others
and wants to keep all his toys to
himself most of the rest of that scene
goes down the same way we saw in the
theatrical version he says who are you
and he introduces himself as Nick Fury
I'm here to talk to you about the
Avenger initiative but in the deleted
version after that iron man says what
the hell are we avenging and Nick Fury
says anything we want the last line
makes it sound like it's a super casual
weekend job so I think it was good that
they got rid of that part and just cut
it at the I'm here to talk to you about
the Avengers BAM slam - black you also
have to keep in mind when this Easter
Egg would have been happening as for
what that crossover of x-men and
spider-man would have looked like I'll
talk about that in a second because it's
really important there's a reason why
it's Tom Holmes spider-man in the MCU
and not another version of spider-man
but number four planning on x-men and
spider-man crossover from the very
beginning back in 2007 when they were
actually shooting this scene clearly
Kevin Feige had been planning on them
eventually getting x-men and spider-man
in the MCU from the very beginning
otherwise they wouldn't have had Sam
Jackson do this scene they were filming
this scene back in 2007 the movie came
out the next year in 2008 they were nine
years away from spider-man crossover and
if we get some x-men tale in Marvel
phase four it will
14 to 15 years away from them filming
this scene that they finally paid the
easter-egg reference off the gamma
incidents that he references during that
is obviously for the Incredible Hulk
movie for the whole crossover which was
gonna happen a couple months after this
scene debuted when that movie dropped
June 2008 radioactive bug bites
obviously as the Spider Man crossover
Easter Egg spider-man bitten by a
radioactive spider the assorted mutants
is the x-men and Deadpool Easter Egg
there are a couple reasons why he's
generic with the mutants term and he
doesn't say x-men specifically but he's
trying to refer to the larger body of
x-men a mutant characters because
there's way more spin-off franchises
from the mainstream x-men characters
they use it mostly as an
all-encompassing term but also for legal
reasons that I'll explain in a second
the writers in Kevin Feige were already
playing it as safe as possible from a
legal perspective by using as generic a
term as possible in referencing the
x-men characters because three they shot
this scene with the intention of putting
it in that first Iron Man movie they
wouldn't have shot it just for fun
because it cost so much money every
minute that they're on set what probably
happened is they shot the scene in a
couple different versions of the scene
with the intention of putting it in the
actual movie then sent a cut of that
scene to their lawyers at Marvel Studios
to see if Fox and Sony could sue them
out of existence just for mentioning
spider-man which was totally controlled
by Sony at that time this was right
after Tobey Maguire spider-man 3 had
dropped when they were still developing
the amazing spider-man reboot with
Andrew Garfield in between x-men The
Last Stand which almost killed that
franchise in x-men origins Wolverine
which almost killed the Wolverine
franchise so you have to imagine that
Kevin Feige is watching the x-men and
the spider-man characters slowly burned
to the ground around him sitting in his
office
seeing how poorly they're being received
secretly hoping that eventually there'd
be some deal that they could work out to
share the characters and they could pay
off this Easter Egg which originally
they intended to actually put in the
film too a lot of you probably know some
of the backstory and how that wound up
happening it took the Sony hack in the
failure of the spider-man franchise
after amazing spider-man 2 for Sony to
be willing to come to the table in
even though Amy Pascal and all these
interviews for spider-man homecoming and
spider-man far from home is a huge Kevin
Feige fan in present day at the time
when they were negotiating to get
spider-man in the MCU she was still head
of the studio she hadn't been pushed out
yet and they had some fierce battles
during the negotiation process
there's the infamous story about her
throwing a sandwich at Kevin Feige
across the boardroom table I think that
we've been friends for a long time we've
been fellows Spider Men lovers for a
long time and Kevin came to me with a
really fabulous idea and I gather
everything bringing spider-man into the
universe where he belongs as all the
fans know interacting with other
characters for the very first time and
it was it seemed like the right time to
do it had the spider-man franchise been
doing really well at that point after
amazing spider-man 2 they would have
gone on to do their sinister six
spin-off franchise there's no way they
would have agreed to share that
character it's just evidence that Marvel
has been trying to make deals with Fox
and Sony to get their characters in the
MCU since the very beginning of the MCU
it's just taken this long to see that
all happen that's how slow things move
in Hollywood in the original version of
events where this scene winds up in the
theatrical cut of Iron Man they
canonized mutants x-men spider-man in
the MCU they probably would have
introduced them in a very house of X
type of way that's happening in the
comics right now they just rebooted
x-men in the Marvel Comics the story now
as the Professor X has been using his
abilities to hide things about mutants
from the world and one day he just flips
that switch on and everybody realizes
what's been going on this whole time is
a very similar problem they have trying
to integrate the Eternals characters
into the MCU which is going to happen
during Marvel phase 4 I've already done
a video explained that like why weren't
they fighting during the Avengers end
game final battle the whole idea is that
x-men mutants the Eternals have been
around this entire time we just haven't
known about it now the x-men explainer
is a little bit different from the
Eternals explainer but it all builds on
pre-existing continuity so first you get
the eternal so you explain how the
Celestials modified human DNA to create
the Celestials but also give humanity
the X gene with their celestial energy
then on top of that you build with the
idea that all the Infinity Gauntlet
snaps release
all that cosmic radiation activating a
lot of those X genes so even though
x-men have been around this whole time
in the MCU on planet Earth you're just
gonna start seeing them now in
combination with a lot of pre-existing
mutants revealing themselves coming out
of hiding like oh we didn't want to
reveal ourselves because we're so
different from humanity in number one
probably the biggest thing is that
originally because the era when this
Easter egg was happening it was right
around tobey maguire spider-man era but
before the Andrew Garfield amazing
spider-man reboot it sounds like
originally when Kevin Feige was thinking
about bringing spider-man into the MCU
circa Ironman one he was thinking about
the Tobey Maguire spider-man if that
doesn't blow your mind there's actually
been somebody that's been doing deep
fakes of Tobey in the MCU recently it's
surreal to watch him walking around
during the endgame battle him with the
Infinity Gauntlet snapping everyone and
on the x-men side of this which x-men
characters would have been popping up
because the Deadpool character had not
debuted yet in Wolverine Origins so
Deadpool was nowhere to be found he
hadn't blown up yet we're talking about
core x-men characters and because it was
happening after x-men Last Stand it just
happened and that franchise was on the
way down it sounds like Kevin Feige had
originally envisioned the Bryan Singer
x-men cast with Patrick Stewart Hugh
Jackman and all those characters to come
into the MCU
if you didn't know it - Kevin Feige got
his start producing films with Lauren
Shuler Donner who was a producer on the
first Bryan Singer x-men film so Kevin
Feige got to be a producer on set sort
of a beginning for modern comic book
films along with that first Tobey
Maguire spider-man film so Kevin Feige
has been doing x-men stuff since the
very beginning that's what he got to
start out before he went over to Marvel
before that became Marvel Studios so
this all goes way back there's super
deep cut Easter eggs for all this you
have to imagine his early days at Marvel
Studios thinking back just a couple
years prior to working with Hugh Jackman
thinking one day I'm gonna bring
Wolverine onto an Avengers team
obviously now in prison day we see Hugh
Jackman in the MCU it's gonna have to be
during Secret Wars because he said he's
pretty much retired from that character
although I do have hopes that he will
return for a cameo Sunday so when they
do debut a new version of Wolverine
it'll be a new actor that they'll recast
everybody post your theories in the
comments how is Marvel going to
introduce
x-men in the MCU during Marvel phase
four Marvel phase 5 and like I said I
will do a giveaway for that giant
infinity saga box set when we get closer
to them actually releasing it I'm still
working on a video about Quicksilver
coming back I'll try to post that in the
next couple of days everybody click here
for my venom 2 teaser including new
spider-man crossover news and click here
for my Avengers Fantastic Four teaser
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]